welcome back to PJ Shan Design This is
PJ today I would like to show you how to
bend the prong in the Rhino 3D program
so that will make your rendering look
realistic and look much nicer are you
ready let's get
[Music]
started a lot of time when we are
working on a jewelry setting and then
you can see that the prong we
intentionally want to leave it a little
bit longer that's enough room for them
to bend over the prong so this is uh the
way that we sent it out for 3D printing
have the prong over the table High which
is a stone table high now coming over
here this is not too good on the
rendering if your customer or client is
request for rendering they don't
understand why the jewelry is so spiky
so a lot of time we need to bend over um
to let them hopping on the top to make
it they look like it's they are finished
and sometime we can even taper the prong
so I'm going to show you two way one is
using the band the other one using the
cage edit and uh the third one's
actually in the subd and I have
including that into my subd course if
you're interesting about my subd course
you can check on the link at the
description below all right that's
starting from the scratch so that's how
we have the setting there disregarding
like how big um the stone is I do have a
video talking about the pron size um on
the Q&A section so we are not going to
go for it so let say this is the setting
and we are having the setting for the
printing uh before you actually Bowling
all the prong to you know the base
underneath it uh you want to do uh the
couple change if you want them to be ban
first of all if this is going to be B
and we only need to deal with one of
them the this one should be a little bit
shorter something like that all right
and when you are going to bend something
over we are going to use the command for
Bend and instead of going from very
bottom and going up and bend like this
which while cutting into the stone you
wanted to see where you're going to bend
it that's say this is where the girdle
where I'm going to bend it so I'm going
to actually starting the AIS from here
here and up and bend it over like this
so that's how you bending the pr uh
often time you're going to see this one
is a little bit bumper so we are going
to go back one step maybe what we need
to do is having them coming even a
little bit more uh lower and sometime
the lazy way you can do is you can just
go so low like that and just having a a
small dot there uh in this case you
might need to moveing in in a little bit
but I still like like to go back with
the uh Bend and see if I can get a good
result there that's using the band
command one more time and we want to go
from here up and bend it a little bit
like this right you don't want to use a
Bend to be too extreme it won't look
good all right so now that's one thing
and once you are done with it you can
actually using the polar array command
snapping into the zero and we need four
of them
360° and then we'll get something like
this so that's one of the way to use it
by using the bang command let's talk
about using the second way to bend the
prong and we only need one prong there
so with this prong I'm going to have
them coming down just a little bit and
we're going to use the commands called
cage
edit when you use the cage cage edit
it's going to ask you to select the
object and we're going to select this
prong and then and right here you have
other uh other many Choice uh we want to
use is bounding box so you can find a
boundary uh within this object and we
want to align to the world so just hit
enter and then you're going to have a
XYZ count so what is important is the Z
count that we need to have lot more
counts so that's uh using maybe 12 and
just keep hitting enter enter one more
time you're going to see those Point
okay so instead of I bending the object
we actually it's going to rotate in
those Point instead so let's go ahead to
using the rotate tool and on those uh
point that we select we want to go
something like this all right and notice
that it is not changing much on the top
not changing much on the bottom but this
area that we rotated is stretch a lot so
we want to kind of uh have this coming
back in something like this and then uh
the good thing about this is uh for the
cage edit you can kind of like giving
them more uh detail edit instead of just
trying to like bend the whole thing so I
can feel like I may need to have this
coming down a little bit like this two
might want to be smashed down just a
little bit and then you can keep editing
and find the shape that you like a lot
of time we also have something more like
a cross uh setting so mean that it's
look like it's really pointed um at the
tip of the prong so what we can also do
is pick up all those point and I want to
count over my command here and we're
going to use this one's called taper all
right so I'm going to uh click on
somewhere in the middle right here
holding my shift click on this end and
then click right here and bring it in
like this all right so that allow you to
make the the prong uh more pointed right
and you can keep editing until you find
a shape that you like I'm going to stop
here if you hit the Escape key then you
will see you can you can get rid of the
point and if you like this no longer
want to use it you can delete the
bounding box um if you need to bring
back the control point you just hit turn
on the control point you will keep
editing until you satisfied okay I feel
like it might be a little bit too
pointed
there so I might want to bring down just
a little bit okay so now I want to
delete this one and let's go ahead to
click this one and we wanted to do the
polar array snapping into the zero and I
wanted to have four of them then we will
have something like
this after that you can use a bowling
different to get rid of anything that is
coming out from the bottom the very last
one is a sub learning jewelry cat it is
not just a cat model we have a model for
rendering we also have a model for
production if you want your jewelry come
to life you need to understand the
production and I'm here to help you in
the following week I'm going to open my
schedule to meet you privately online
together we're going to brainstorming a
great study plan for you to understand
jewelry care design for production if
you are interested to meet me privately
sign up link is in the description below
hope to see you in the meeting thank you
for watching and I'll see you next
[Music]